タンッ(笑顔)
うわあ
ドライアイスがっ
はい
はい、と言うわけで今売っているサーティーワンのアイスクリームを
全種類をここに買ってきました
俺多分、え、
やった人いないと思うんですよ、わかんない
ちょっとYouTube見てない
サーティーワンアイスクリームを
全種類混ぜるひt…
ガタッ…
やらせてくださいぃ
やらせてくださいよぉぉぉぉすみません
え、めっちゃ皆やってんじゃん
それも一人どころじゃない
びっっっくりするぐらいいろんな人がやってますね
ただわたくし、昔やってみる皆さんとは大きく違うところが1点あります
こちら全種類
この中には当時売ってなかった
伝説のフレーバーが含まれています
それは何かと言いますと
藤田ニコルさんがプロデュースした伝説のフレーバーが入っているので
昔他の人たちがやっていた
サーティワンのアイスクリームを全部混ぜてみたらどんな味になるの？みたいなやつとは
違う味になってると思うんですよフレーバ一が1つ変わるだけでも
藤田ニコルさんありがとうございます
強欲な壺
普通にみんなやってて普通に今萎えてます
いやでも買っちゃたら仕方ないんで
やります！
ここまできたら普通にねぇもう美味しいやつを作りたい
とりあえず全部開封していきましょう
ﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯﾊﾟｯ
うわああぁぁぁあああぁぁあぁああぁああぁ
みんなとネタは被っているが全然違います
なぜならこのフレーバーの中には
にこるんが作った　ハニー…
レモンハニーが入っているので
味は絶対変わっています
フレーバーが1つ変わるだけでも全然味のそのニュアンスが違ってくるんで
普通に食べたいんですけど
突撃！！！
もう混ぜる用の容器を買ってきたんで
まずはこちら“クリームソーダ”
ドンッ
“レインボーシャーベット”
ドン
“サーティワンラブ”
“チョコレートオレンジヘーゼルナッツ”
トン
“ポッピンコットンキャンディ”
ドン
“ラズベリーフロマージュ”
トン
“杏仁豆腐”
ペチ
“ロックンロールチョコレート”
ベコッ
“アイスクリームハント”
ドンッ
“バニラ”
“ラブポーションサーティワン”
ドン
“ラムレーズン”
ドンッ
“ジャモカコーヒー”
ドン
“抹茶”
すいません本気で溶けそうなのではしょります
うわぁ結構やっぱカラフルになりますねぇ
さぁ〜こっから混ぜていきましょう
わぁ待ってすごいすごい！原宿ぅ〜
待ってホントになんかちょっと待って
うわぁ色がもう
すごいちゃんとねほんとシャッフルしたいんすよね
これだと多分ちょっとこういうね層になっちゃうんで
ちゃんと混ぜるためにミキサー使います
(ミキサー音)
うわぁすげー頑張ってる
おーおぉおぉおぉぉぉぅすごい
うわぁすげーめっちゃ混ざってる
結構混ざってきました
結構いい感じに溶けてる
ああああぁぁあぁぁぁああぁぁあぁぁぁ
ｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞ
ﾊｧｯﾊｧﾊｧﾊｧﾊｧ
すげーめっちゃもうミキサー使ったら100倍混ざりました
ただ色的な話をすると
すいませんではとりあえず1口だけ食べてみましょう
見た目はチョコですねぇ
うわぁ
マシュマロ味？えー？
みんなあああああぁぁぁああぁぁ！
来てくれええぇぇえぇぇえぇぇぇ！
あの1口だけ食って何味かだけ教えて
【はじめしゃちょーエンディング】
なんて？ｗ
ビオフェルミン？？
ビオフェルミンこれビオフェルミンだよ
知ってるっしょ？